how to live without fear or without
worry
all those of you who are worrying about
something raise your right hand
okay i am so sorry to see
so many hands
by the end of the sermon if i were to
ask that question i should see no hands
because god can make changes
instantaneously
how long did it take god to convert saul
from a murdering persecuting zealot to a
child of god how long did that take
like that
when jesus comes back
this corruptable
shall put on incorruption
in how much time
twinkling
of an eye
when a man or a woman comes to christ
acknowledges his or her undone condition
recognizes the need for a power outside
of himself or herself and the urgent
need for a savior and the person
confesses and says lord save me how long
does it take conversion to occur
like that
then it continues
when peter was sinking
and he said lord
save
me
how long did it take jesus to save him
like that
for some reason we have this mentality
that it takes god a long time to change
things about us
if that is the case it takes god a long
time because it takes us a long time to
come to the place where we say lord i
want you to do this for me 100
now when we reach that point
it does not take god
long not long at all
answer if you've come in here tonight
riddled with worry
you should leave
released
and free
matthew 6 reading from verse 19.
matthew 6 reading from verse 19 for
public reading we use oh i use
the king james version
how many are here for the first time i
see your hands
god bless you god bless you
god bless you
anyone from far away tonight far away
where are you from
where
what did he say
ontario ontario canada
all right well that's far and we
appreciate your sacrifice in making the
trip in one day
to be here we appreciate that very much
anyone else
far away where are you from
toronto okay we have some regional
friends right there okay yes my good
brother
washington
spokane washington as opposed to
washington d.c all right
well it's good to have you wherever
you're from
god's hands are not too short that they
cannot save whether you're from ontario
toronto spokane or the moon
god can reach you
and save you somebody say amen
yes you can do you have matthew 6
do you have verse 19
the bible says lay not up for yourselves
treasures upon earth
where moth and rust doth corrupt
and where thieves breakthrough and steal
but lay up for yourselves treasures in
heaven
where neither moth nor rust doth corrupt
and where thieves do not break through
nor steal
for where your treasure is there will
your heart be also let's examine these
three verses from the lips of jesus
christ himself
jesus gives us a choice
two choices
for the depositing of that which we hold
valuable
either on earth
or in heaven
and so he gives us some advice
lay not up for yourselves treasures upon
earth
where moth
and rust doth corrupt
now what are treasures
that which is important and valuable to
us
it can also mean your money
it can mean
your influence is it an influence that
points people heavenward or is it an
influence that points people downward
which one does god want you and me to
exert
jesus says lay up your treasures
in heaven
because there are no morphs
there is no rust
consequently there is no corruption
that which we do for god that which
tends to point people towards heaven
there is no corruption possible
and verse 21 tells us for where your
treasure is there will your heart be
also the heart obviously means the mind
a few years ago i was preaching
in the church of a friend of mine he's a
preacher
not sure where he is now
and he was telling me a story about a
car he had bought
it was top of the line in that
particular model or make i'm not sure
what the word is
and he said when his car was parked
outside the church on sabbath mornings
and he's the pastor
he is on the pulpit waiting for his time
to preach
and his mind
was not on the sermon
he told me his mind dwelt on these
questions who is parking next to me
who is looking at my car
is someone scratching my car
that's where his heart was because all
that he was with respect to image was
wrapped up in that piece of metal and
rubber
he said to me i decided
i had to sell that car
he said i sold it
i bought another car
that allows me to think of other things
when i'm on the pulpit
he said now i don't think who parks next
to me when i'm doing god's work my mind
is heavenward not earthword
wherever we put that which is valuable
to us that's where our minds are that's
what we worry about that's what causes
anxiety and loss of sleep
and jesus says don't do that
that which is most valuable to us he
says let us lay that up
in heaven
because if that's where our treasure is
that's where our minds will be focused
you see god who made us understands us
now god has nothing against having
treasures let me say that as clearly as
i possibly can
how many of you have ever heard of the
book councils on stewardship let me see
your hands
hands down those of you who've never
heard of the book councils of
stewardship raise your hand
all right a lot of hands
i hope the abc has enough copies for all
of my friends who have never heard of
councils on stewardship let me give you
a statement in that book page 148
paragraph two
the writer is a lady called ellen white
tremendous woman somebody say a man with
me tremendous woman
here's what she wrote and if you buy
that book and you read it you will
wonder who is this woman
here's what she said
the desire to accumulate wealth
is an original impulse
of the heart
implanted there
by our heavenly father
for noble ends
for me in that quotation the key word is
noble
because noble has nothing to do with you
it has to do with someone else
noble has nothing to do with me it has
to do with someone else let me give you
that quotation again as we talk about
how to live without fear
the impulse of the desire
to accumulate wealth is an original
impulse the word original means it goes
back to eden
implanted there by our heavenly father
for noble ends noble reasons noble
objectives and i repeat a noble
objective has nothing to do with me
and if you permit the false grammar with
i
it has to do
with someone else
so even in an unfallen state it was
god's desire that mankind would meet the
needs of others whatever needs unfallen
people might have had
so christ is not against having
treasures
all he tells us to do be careful where
you deposit your treasure now how do i
deposit treasures in heaven i support
the work of god
i see someone in need and i assist
because jesus enunciates a very serious
principle in as much as you have done it
unto one of the least of these my
brethren finish it for me
you have done it unto me that's a
deposit in heaven because jesus pays his
debts
you know what jesus told the rich young
ruler luke chapter 18
when he said all these have i kept from
my youth up
and jesus heard that he said
go sell all that thou hast and
distribute to the poor and thou shalt do
what
have treasure
in heaven
jesus lets us know one way to save up
treasure in heaven is to give to people
down here
not one amen
a couple more
are we opposed to giving to people
does not your bible say it is more
blessed to do what
than to
how many of us believe it
yes
lay not up for yourselves
treasures upon earth
remorse and rust does corrupt and with
thieves break through and steal says
your jesus and mine
but lay up for yourselves notice this is
not selfishness but notice the word
christ uses lay up for yourselves there
is a place in the christian life to look
out for yourself
wherefore beloved as ye have always
obeyed not as in my presence only but
now much more in my absence work out
somebody else's salvation with fear and
trembling
work out your own there is a place in
salvation for looking out for yourself
that is not selfishness that is making
sure that between god and me there is no
obstacle there are no barriers between
god and me that's looking out for me
in the context of god
and so jesus says
lay up
for yourselves
you're a professor in a classroom
do you know how many people have gone
into professions because they were
influenced by a teacher
teachers have tremendous influence on
students students of any age you are a
christian professor you're standing
before your class what is your desire to
impress the students with your knowledge
or to exert an influence that saves
where will you lay up your treasure
because if that person is saved that
person becomes a living treasure to your
account
where your treasure is
there will your heart
your mind you see on the earth
there is anxiety
there is fear
there is worry
there is uncertainty there's enron there
are things like that
jesus says that's not the place to
invest
that does not happen in heaven there are
no crashes of the stock market in heaven
there's no
depression error in heaven
an investment in heaven pays dividends
eternally investment on this earth comes
to a fiery end do you understand me
so jesus says
you want your heart
on heaven
put your treasures in heaven
let me make a guess about some of you
there are some people listening to me
now who are quite wealthy
i want to ask for show of hands because
you may have a long line of people
following you home
there are people listening to me
with money to spare
but because they don't like the pastor
the church didn't put down the carpet
they wanted
they don't like
somebody else
they don't like the way the church does
evangelism
they refuse to give as a punitive
response
absolutely refuse
let me tell you something else this nice
lady called ellen white said i don't
recall where i read it i read it
all the money required to finish the
gospel
you know where it is
in the church
why is the gospel not finished
all the money or she used to say all the
means
required to complete the work that
people may go home that sickness may
come to land death disease suffering
starvation genocide may come to an end
it is in the church
you know god is omnipotent but i have
learned there's some things he can't do
one of the things he can't seem to do is
get the money out of his people
now money does his haggai to eight all
the silver and the gold mine
the earth is the lord's and the fullness
thereof the world and they that well
they're in is his but we hold on to it
with the tenacity of a
half starved pit bull will not let go
lay not up for yourselves treasures upon
earth
lay up our treasures by the advice of
jesus christ in heaven
7 30 as we continue
how to live without fear
let's go to verse 22
matthew 6
the light of the body
is the i
if therefore thine eye be single
thy whole body shall be full of light
but if thine eye be evil thy whole body
shall be full of darkness if therefore
the light that is in thee be darkness
how great is that darkness now jesus is
saying
we need or he needs people with eyes
that are single
i'm not saying he wants one-eyed people
he's he wants people
who are focused
unswervingly
you know i've noticed when horses that
those racehorses
they wear these things on their eyes
and my guess is having never consulted a
jockey my guess is that they don't see
the horses next to them
unless
the horses several furlongs in front of
him they don't see what's happening to
the right or to the left they just look
ahead and jesus says i need people whose
eyes are single to my work to my cause
and to my glory
single
let me tell you how i've learned not to
worry when i go to preach
whenever i can
and people tell me we are considering
calling you
i write back and i say that's nice
get together a few names of people who
could do it even better than i can
think of some people
now pray over those
names if the spirit of god convicts you
that i am the one you call me
too often we invite people because they
speak well we don't care whether they
have a relationship with christ or not
he speaks well or she speaks well or she
sings well or he pastors a large church
those are the basis on which we invite
people to speak
no one would have invited john the
baptist on those grounds
so my request always is pray
if you're convicted
then call me now if that call comes now
i go
with no worry
no fear
no concern because i go with the
conviction
i am going where god wants me to go
and i know if i need something somehow
god will provide it if an obstacle
arises god will remove it because god
when god sends you he takes care of you
and so when i go i go on a mission
and people on the mission don't look for
luxury
they have one focus
the mission
you know you men sitting here you know
football
there's
i grew up in the west indies we didn't
have football
but i came to united states i watched it
and i the thing about football that
impresses me most
two things
the running back
and the wide receiver
two perilous ways to make money
i am told i used to counsel
an athlete who won the heisman trophy
now that's not laying up trash in heaven
i just thought i'd tell you
he did win the heisman trophy in 91 name
is desmond howard by the way fine young
man
and i counsel other players at the
university of michigan who went on to
play professional football
and they tell me and i saw and i heard
when the running back is running he has
the ball
here's the line right over there that's
the goal line
now he is not to concern himself with
the fact that a man on this side
weighing 300 pounds
and a man on this side weighing about
and a man over here coming right in
front of him when 290
they are all converging on his ribs he
is not to be concerned with that
he is to be concerned with getting that
ball to break the line the goal line
once it breaks the plane they tell me
that's a touchdown that's all he is
concerned about
and if he is hit he's not supposed to go
down
he's supposed to take the hit if they
hang on to him he is supposed to carry
them because he has one mission his eye
is single break the plane now the wide
receiver they tell me
you must catch the ball with your eyes
and the saying i've heard is look the
ball into your hands
don't worry about the feet you hear
have faith
catch the ball
regardless of the man who is coming to
separate your head
from your neck
and you're not to take your eye off the
ball now jesus says if then i be single
how many teams would win games if every
time the wide receiver goes up for catch
he's looking around to see who's coming
and christians we must learn to put our
eyes on the business of god and not look
around but the world is a past master at
distracting us
so we look
here's the gospel ball jesus throws it
he says catch it run with it and we
start to run
and we hear the peter petter of fashion
and we turn
like that
the ball is in the air about to drop
my next paycheck i've got to get one
church building not finished but that's
okay i've got to get that
all the world comes up with something
else for here to pit a pattern of some
other distraction whatever it may be and
our eyes leave the ball that jesus has
thrown in
and jesus looks for men and women who
will get put their eyes on that ball and
not take it off when that becomes your
only
obsession
you do not worry
about what's around you
if thine eye be single
to the glory of god
if any man had a reason to look around
it was jesus going up calvary
but he kept his eye on the summit of
that hill because on the summit of that
hill through the eye of faith he saw all
the souls that would be saved by his
sacrifice
and would not be distracted
now let's look at verse 24 matthew 6 as
we continue how to live without fear
jesus says no man can serve two masters
do you know most people try
now jesus didn't say you should not
serve two masters
he did not say that
he announces
an absolute impossibility
no man
no woman can serve two masters it cannot
happen
which means
that if i am not serving god
can i finish
will you still love me
you finish it
yes if you are not serving god you are
serving another power however polite you
may be and calm and poised and educated
and well-mannered and
smooth and silky and sophisticated and
swarf
that same woman i like to talk about
she said in the book great controversy
mention the hands of those who have
never heard of great controversy raise
your hand quickly never heard of it
got to get that young man a copy
handsome fellow he needs that book
nice looking man over here nice looking
people need great controversy say amen
get him one
she said
satan's most effective agents
are people
whom you never suspect
they are respectable in the church in
the community as i said well-mannered
well-spoken
educated
cultured
can tell you who painted that painting
as opposed to who painted this one
but they are agents of the devil meaning
that to be an agent of the devil you
need not have your eyes rolled back into
your head and form at the mouth
you just have to be
one who attempts to serve god part-time
and serve the devil part-time you are
effectively serving the enemy full-time
no man
i don't care who you are
can serve two masters
but i repeat 20 minutes to eight
most christians try to do it
because if i say
in my heart
i am not 100 a child of god
who has the other percentage that god
doesn't have
and since god does not share
who has me
every
person not holy committed to christ
is under the influence of another power
let me repeat that with great respect
every man or woman whether seated here
or standing in the pulpit not fully
committed to christ is under the power
the control of another power
have the only two powers in the universe
one have a very short longevity it's
coming to an end quickly
no man matthew 6 24 can serve two
masters
now here is the attitude jesus wants
from you and me
notice the wording he uses
for either
either means how many are involved
two
for either he will hate the one
and what's the word
love the other what do you call those
two words
opposites extremes fine
opposites
now when you and i are confronted with
there is no guesswork in opposites
in other words
if i
love god
that's one extreme
and i hate the devil that's another
extreme my love for god will become very
evident
but if some people or if your neighbors
your your church members your colleagues
are not sure if you're christian
we have got a problem
and god is not morally obligated to take
care of you
because you're not his
for either he will hit the one
and love the other
or else he will haul to the one and
despise the other he cannot serve god
and mammon says jesus christ who is the
word the truth
but i repeat with respect
many of us try
and that trial can end before we leave
here tonight
now if
your treasures are being stored up in
heaven
versus
19-21 if
your eye is single to god's glory verses
22 and 23 and if you are serving one
master jesus christ verse 24 if these
things are in place then verse 25 makes
sense to you and to me
therefore i say unto you because of
these therefore i say unto you take no
thought for your life
don't worry
people just read verse
25 and forget 21 through 24.
the word therefore in 25 connects it
with what went before
so jesus is saying if your focus is
heaven if your eyes are single to my
glory if i am the only master you serve
then don't worry
take no thought for your life what you
shall eat
or what you shall drink know yet for
your body what you shall put on it's not
the life more than meat and the body
than raiment
in other words there's more to life
than the physical
there is something more important that's
what jesus is saying but too many of us
we act as though the physical is more
important than the spiritual jesus says
that's wrong
verse 26
behold the fouls of the air
they so not neither reap nor gather into
barns yet your heavenly father feed of
them are ye not much better than they
look at the wording of jesus christ he
says your heavenly father feet of them
he does not say
their heavenly father feet of them
and that's deliberate
it stresses a point which is this
if
your father
will feed that which is not his child
will he not feed you
yes
god created the birds
but he never died for the birds they
weren't made in his image in that sense
and to that degree he is not the father
of the birds he is our father
and notice the words are ye not much
better than they in the eyes of god you
and i are here the birds are here
let me say that again the bible gives
clear instructions to treat animals
kindly
but the bible is also clear
we are of more value in god's eyes than
many sparrows
now if notice christ's word are he not
much more how much is much more it
sounds gargantuan and gigantic to me
tremendous difference now jesus says if
my father cares for a living organism
that far down the totem pole of
importance
and you
are at the top of that poll
what right do you have
to worry
don't you understand jesus says when you
worry you make me look bad because the
angels of the fallen angels other
intelligences perhaps look around and
they say well why is he worrying what
kind of father does he have
it is a sin
to worry
go ahead and throw whatever you want to
throw at me
it is a sin to worry
if you're child of god
if you belong to the world that's what
you ought to do
am i being too harsh
no
all right
which of you verse 27 by taking thought
can add one cubit to his statue
and why take he thought for raymond
consider the lilies of the field how
they grow
they're toil not
neither do they spin
yet i say unto you that even solomon in
all his glory was not arrayed like one
of these
a blade of grass
a flower
was more gloriously arrayed than solomon
in his finest regalia why because god
dressed it
don't you see what jesus is doing to his
children
he is pointing them to the great creator
behold the fowls of the air
they were made on day five
genesis 1 20
and god said let the waters bring forth
abundantly the moving creature that hath
life and foul that may fly above the
earth in the open firmament of heaven
jesus says he who made the fouls
and sustains what he makes will take
care of you
then he says consider the lilies of the
field then in verse 30 says wherefore if
god so clothed the grass of the field
well the lilies of the grass they were
made on the third day of creation
genesis 1 11 the bible says and god said
let the earth bring forth grass
he is pointing them to the creator you
see we've got to connect salvation with
creation
and the god who said let there be light
the god who said let the earth bring
forth grass
the god who said let the waters bring
forth abundantly the moving creature
that hath life is the same god
that will provide and he provides the
same way
by his word his divine fiat
his spoken command when god commands
that you'll be taken care of you will be
taken care of and i
but the key is
how many masters
are we serving
we have to serve one
i recommend
the create of heaven and earth
based on scripture first of all
and my personal
experience
and countless testimonies i have heard
the child of god
should not worry let me show you how
jesus contrasts what our behavior should
be with those in the world
verse 30 says of matthew 6 wherefore if
god so clothed the grass of the field
which today is and tomorrow is cast into
the oven in other words the grass comes
up and it's gone and jesus still cares
shall he not much more clothe you o ye
of little faith
verse 31
wherefore take no thought saying what
shall we eat or what shall we drink or
with all shall we be clothed for after
all these things do whom
the gentiles seek or luke 12 30 says the
nations of the world for after all these
things of the gentiles seek for your
heavenly father knoweth that he have
need of what
how many things
all
god knows
i believe
and the scripture seems to support it
we find ourselves begging god for a lot
of things
because somewhere in us
because of our divided loyalties
we don't expect
the bountiful blessings of god
jesus says
your heavenly father
knows
that you need
all these things
he knows it
you don't have to beg
verse 33 now notice he uses the word
seek
for after all these things do the
gentiles do what
seek
now there's nothing wrong with seeking
the problem is in what order we seek
we shall see the word seek again
verse 33 but what
seek ye what
first why does jesus use the word first
becomes it comes ahead of seeking what
food
clothing
all the other things he listed that he
knows we need he says seek the kingdom
first
that is the chronology a child of god
follows step by step the kingdom of god
first and his righteousness
now what do the gentiles seek first
the things for physical living
jesus says after all these things do the
gentiles seek so jesus expects the
gentiles to be seeking and the child of
god to be seeking now here comes a being
from pluto and he's observing gentiles
seeking and he's observing christians
seeking there ought to be a difference
in the seeking
the child of god
seeks the kingdom of god and his
righteousness and so this alien watches
this group the children of god and he
notices they seek differently
then he watches this group and they seek
differently and he understands there is
an ocean of difference
in the seeking
if we would follow the chronology
jesus lays down in matthew 6 33
with all our hearts
having established clearly verse 24
we're serving one master
worry
and fear
anxiety
uncertainty
would evaporate
from our lives
when god sent the manner in the
wilderness
how much mana did he send for tuesday
enough for what
tuesday
how much did he send for sunday
enough
for sunday
what does that tell you how should we
live
one
day
at a time
now let me ask you this
can god feed you for just one day
yes
can the salvation army feed you for one
day
yes
can i in a fit of generosity give you a
sandwich for one day
yes
but you ask someone to do it for you 50
years you may get what
50 years
but that's how we live
you look at a man who's been smoking 40
years and we tell him can you give it up
for the rest of your life
can you give it up today
just for the day
that's all
who told you you have the rest of your
life
do you have a receipt
and so jesus says in verse 34 they take
therefore no thought for the moral don't
worry listen god does not give you any
blessing on sunday night to be used for
monday
i can wait until 8 30 for what i'm
waiting for
amen
you really treat me badly you know that
let me repeat
god does not give a blessing on sunday
that you need for monday
the blessing you get on sunday is for
sunday because god may decide to take
your life on monday or sunday night
it's one day at a time
now you may plan for tomorrow
but live for today
let me say that again
you can plan for tomorrow
but live
for today
because today is all we have
and so jesus says
take no thought for your life what you
shall eat or what you shall drink not
yet for your body what you shall put on
seek ye first
the kingdom of god
and his righteousness
that's it
how do you seek it
how do you seek it tell someone about
jesus
how do you seek it psalm 139 23 search
me oh god
there's something in me i don't even
know exists
but since i am me there must be
something in me you search find it dig
it out
seek ye first the kingdom of god
and his righteousness
i didn't promise to let you out at eight
can you give me until five after
can you do that
all right that's all i need
and all these things
shall be added
unto you
all
the verses will say if you ask
they will simply
be added
if we seek the kingdom first god just
gives us certain things
because he knows
if he gives then we keep seeking the
kingdom if he does not give we stop
seeking the kingdom to go get them
i am not spiritualizing
our temporal responsibilities
you work for a bank tomorrow go to work
you work cleaning the street go clean it
but in the cleaning of the street
you can seek the righteousness of jesus
christ
in working at the bank you can seek the
righteousness of jesus christ in your
professorial role you can seek the
righteousness of jesus christ because
there is no time however microscopic
when the child of god can say well this
is mine and i won't try to be like god
because that's all the time the devil
needs
because he works fast
and so i say to you from my heart as we
close
god will take care of us
but our focus
must be heavenly
we are too concerned with that which is
secular
and we are riddled with uncertainties
and doubt and crises that are entirely
unnecessary if we would only redirect
our focus and put it on heavenly things
where there is certainty
i mean certainty
where your treasure is
there will your heart be also
i have to ask you
if i didn't ask you i'd be responsible
to god i must ask you
have you been seeking the kingdom of god
in his righteousness
i cannot read your heart you cannot read
mine and i'm glad for that i'm sure
you're glad for that
but god can our hearts are open books
as you and i sit where we sit and stand
where we stand
if god showed up and stood in your face
and mine
and he can do that just by having you
die tonight i'm not trying to scare you
people die people are dying right now
they're being shot dying from disease
dying of heart attacks brain tumors
crime
old age
suicide they are dying
right
now
then why is god keeping us alive why
is it possible he's giving us another
chance to get right with him
i have four minutes left
is no one here tired
of playing with god
any man or woman
who will say with me lord
give me the mind of christ
that i may seek your kingdom
first
if you will say that with me
give me
the mind of christ that i will seek your
kingdom first
raise your right hand
now don't don't make me feel good raise
it leave it up
stand up with me
let's pray
our father in heaven
i come to you in the name of jesus
i am one with my brothers and sisters
who have sat before me and listened
as i try to speak the words you've laid
on my heart
father my prayer for them is my prayer
for myself
we must be sure
that we seek your kingdom first
always
and only
lord if we are not holy yours we are
under the control of another power help
us to understand that
dear god in heaven
let us reread matthew 6 24 even now
no man
can serve two masters
father if there's a man
or a woman who knows that he or she has
been serving two masters which
ultimately is serving the wrong one
i pray in the name of jesus you would
lay a conviction upon that person's
heart so heavy the person will have no
rest
until he or she decides to love jesus
and hate the enemy and hold on to jesus
and despise the enemy
do this for us i pray
please
oh god open our eyes to see that the
time is short
the times are critical
and we must be sure as joshua said as
for me and my house
regardless of what the church does
family members do as for me and my house
must be our individual prayer we
will serve
the lord
lord let this be our song and our anthem
that i as an individual will lay up
treasures in heaven my eye will be
single to your glory and i will serve
you and you alone that i may understand
your words which say take no thought for
the moral
now bless my beloved spiritual family
take them safely home and bring us back
on tuesday but as we go let your words
sink through the soil of our minds down
to the very subconscious and change it
from that level
hear us i pray
i offer this prayer in jesus name and
for his sake let all god's people say
with me amen
and amen god bless you